la suite de notre grande enquête sur les
surrégénérateurs une enquête dont le
point d'orgue sera question de temps
lundi à 20h30 fait que nous avons
accompagné quatre parlementaires rpr udf
rpr udf ps et pc tout autour du monde
pressé de savoir ce que faisait les
autres grandes nations et bien ce soir
d'un endroit bien symbolique hiroshima
charline nous présente les tenants et
les aboutissants de cette enquête
hiroshi bas c'est ici il ya trente cinq
ans que la première bombe atomique est
tombé 200 mille morts depuis témoigne de
cette utilisation
magnifique du nucléaire mais ce pays le
japon qui pourtant a expérimenté dans sa
chair la bombe atomique et qui en
conserve les traces n'a pas hésité à se
lancer dans l'utilisation pacifique du
nucléaire
et depuis a construit vingt-et-une
centrales nucléaires c'est plus qu'en
france
mais comme la france le japon s'est mis
maintenant à construire le surgénérateur
c'est un choix qui est contesté c'est un
choix qui provoque un débat est parce qu
il provoque un débat antenne 2 et europe
1 ont décidé de demander à quatre
députés français représentant les quatre
grandes familles politiques françaises
de faire un tour du monde du nucléaire
à l'issue de ce tour du monde en 18
jours rendez vous donc sur antenne 2 et
sur europe 1 du 22 septembre prochain au
29 septembre